Good morning John.
Thank you for your video Monday where you
explained all the ways in which the world
has actually gotten a lot better in the last
15 years, which would indicate that we have
the ability to make it even better in the
next 15 years.
But there was a problem with your video, John.
It's that you made your video about good news,
and we are cognitively biased to be both disinterested
in and kind of skeptical of good news.
Especially when that good news is so large
scale that we can't really get emotionally
involved in it.
It's kinda difficult to care.
So I'm gonna be taking a different tack, John.
Today, right now, as a 193 leaders throughout
the world sign on to the UN Global Goals for
the next 15 years, I don't care how much better
things have gotten because they still suck!
I don't like outrage for outrage's sake.
I don't like the news getting me all riled
up about things that don't really matter that
much.
I want to be angry that children are dying,
that gender inequality exists pretty much
everywhere on Earth, that 6 million people
will die this year because they don't have
access to clean water!
The world is messed up.
But we have a plan.
There are 17 Global Goals, each with a number
of outlined distinct targets that the UN is
asking every nation on Earth to help us all
achieve by 2030.
And you know what the chances of us pulling
that off are if nobody cares about it?
Zero, absolutely zero.
We basically need every person on Earth to
know about these goals because they are achievable
and we can do this, but only if people hold
their governments accountable.
Only if we care!
So discover the joy with me, of being pissed
off for a good reason!
Not in opposition of some other group of people,
but an absolute agreement with everybody on
Earth.
Every child on Earth should go to school.
No one should be hungry.
No one should be in extreme poverty.
And corrupt governments and greed should not
stand in the way of these goals.
And I don't mean to be a doom-sayer, but it's
not gonna matter if we achieve these goals
if we build them on top of an unsustainable
exploitation of our planet!
In order for this world to make the kind of
investments it needs to achieve these goals,
we have to care.
We have to hold our leaders accountable.
And if you do care, then you kind of definitionally
have to be angry!
Because it's infuriating!
So get angry!
Choose the Global Goal that resonates the
most with you, draw that on your face with
some eyeliner or some Sharpie, I don't care!
Share with all your people!
Put it on your Instagrams and on your Snapchats
and Facebooks!
I don't care where you put it!
SHARE IT WITH THE WORLD!
PEOPLE HAVE TO KNOW!
Did I spit on you?!
Oh I'm sorry that's so unfortunate for you!
GET UP!
SHARE THE GLOBAL GOALS!
PRINT OUT A POSTER AT GLOBALGOALS.ORG!
PUT IT UP IN YOUR SCHOOL CAMPUS OR YOUR OFFICE
OR AROUND YOUR TOWN OR SHOW IT TO YOUR MOM!
Share this with the rest of the world because
we have gone half way and that is not far
enough!
Let it out with me!
Feel it with me!
Scream at the SPECTER OF INJUSTICE AND UNFAIRNESS!
And then go to globalgoals.org, find out what
all the fuss is about, pick your favorite
goal.
Draw it on your face or have a friend do it
'cause I found out it's actually quite hard
to draw something on your own face.
Share it, let people know what the heck's
going on, why they should know about this,
and why they maybe should be a little angry
and also a little optimistic about the future
of life here on Earth.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
I'm honestly amazed at how far we've come,
at how much infant mortality has decreased,
at how much education and access to clean
water has increased.
There's a tremendous amount of good news,
but I really-- I'm not being like tongue-in-cheek
in this.
I'm actually, like, I think that if we're
gonna get angry about anything, this is the
stuff to get angry about.
And it's kind of hard, because it isn't like
one thing and it doesn't feel like "argh that's
so frustrating that this one thing happened."
It's big!
It's big and it's hard to get your mind around,
and it's impossible to believe that we can
actually do stuff about this, but we can.
The UN exists for a reason and the Global
Goals are an actual plan, and I am really
amazed by them, and really inspired by them.
And I really do hope that you will be inspired,
whoever this is watching, will be inspired
to share this stuff with the people around
you and in your life and in your community.
So yeah I'm angry, and I yelled at you.
I apologize for that, if it was a little freaky,
but I think that we can do this stuff.
But only if we hold our leaders accountable,
and if we really want it to happen.
And of all the things I want to happen most
in the world, the achievement of the Global
Goals is #1 on the list.
I will never be angry again if we can just
pull this off.